hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that comes as a suggestion
from iron damani
uh it's a game from the 2013 tournament
in beijing
china uh the sport accord world mind
games and it's a game from round seven
vasily vancouver versus anish giri and
it features the greatest opening ever
not the greatest gambit ever the
greatest opening ever but also a very
nice gambit and that is of course the
king's gambit
and uh we haven't covered all that many
games
[Music]
regarding the king's gambit we covered
some especially in the morphe saga and
in the older games but
in modern times not really and is this
really
uh the greatest um uh king's gambit game
that was played uh it's hard to say uh
because
there are there are some of them being
played and some of them are really great
but
uh that's why i chose the title so you
guys can suggest
uh if there are some other games past
2013
that featured uh king's gambit maybe a
nice miniature maybe you know
where good things happen uh but that
being said let's check it out as
uh vasil has the white pieces and he
opens
with e4 we have e5 by anish and now f4
going for the king's gambit of course
he captures on f4 he's played by giri
he's an honorable person
whenever someone plays the kings again
but against you have to accept it
that's that's how it works although
nowadays uh if you play this in a blitz
game or in a bullet game most people
will just go for the
counter gambit so a forwards counter
gambit because that also gives black
uh so much counter play but he captures
an f4 there is nothing wrong with that
and now
uh the most often way to play against
black is knight to f3 but
i just because it's the most open way to
play it's not
maybe the best because of course geary
knows how to play against this
so here we have bishop to c4 going for
the bishops gambit and now
here white is asking black do you want
to go for this check and going for this
check is something that
might be you know playable in for
example 1850
but nowadays it's it's just going to be
really really hard to play
yeah for example king to f1 and you
don't care you haven't castle because
next you're playing knight to f3 and
you're gonna start developing all of
your pieces with
uh with tempo as the the black queen is
very weirdly placed here on h4
for example knight f6 we're gonna attack
the queen and now after
you you move this queen knight c3 then
d4 then the the bishop comes alive
and it's um even though it might be
playable for uh for an engine
um you know a human might struggle with
it a bit too much
so instead after bishop to c4 we have
the immediate knight to f6
and now knight to c3 developing and
defending we have c6 now controlling
this knight on c3
and now bishop to b3 as you know black
is uh
preparing d5 so here we have d5 and now
you have to capture
if you go for e5 then knights to e4 and
now it's it's black who's just uh you
know
all over the board that's not what what
you want to see so instead after d5 we
have e
captures on d5c captures and now d4
so grabbing more space in the center we
have bishop to d6
now defending this pawn and here we have
knight g to e2
uh sometimes uh black can play in a way
that
after he accepts um the gambit with e
captures on f4 he's going to try and
defend this pawn but
this this usually never works out so
here there are some games that reach
this exact same position for example
there's one
uh not so long ago into in 2021 uh yanni
pomnishi tried it against levin arne and
he played
bishop g4 here or rather uh
11 played bishop to g4 here and he won a
very nice game against nepal it was in
the magnus carlsen invitational
and also there's a game from 2013 some
six months before this game between evan
chuke and
and geary uh were cat were simply
castles was it was played it was between
simon williams and marcus raga and
defeated williams here uh but for this
game anish wanted something special he
wanted to play in great style and he
played f3 so he's giving back the pawn
voluntarily and now he says all right
at least i'm going to mess up your your
pawn structure in front of the king
but this is maybe exactly what uh what
vasil
wants because he wants the castle queen
side he doesn't want to castle king side
and since geary will be castling king
side he's going to use the open g file
for the attack
but okay that is why we're showing the
game so g
captures on f3 uh anish castles here and
now
bishop to g5 so now the queen will move
he will castle queen side and then he's
going to try to use the open g file semi
open g file for attacking purposes
uh we have bishop to e6 and now queen to
d2
as planned now preparing to castle queen
side bishop to e7 now the knight can
move
and here we have queen side castles and
it is now
as of move 12 that we have a completely
new game but also
a position that has never been reached a
game since uh some of you asked me why
do i say this i say it's a completely
new game if i'm covering a game from
2021
or modern games but if i cover a game
from 1942
uh then i'm gonna say it's a position
that has never been reached again
because uh you know it's weird to say
it's a completely new
position uh if the position happened 150
years ago so that's why i use it but
it's basically the same stuff
so here after this queenside castles we
have knights to c6
just continuing development and now uh
while you might throw in a nice
prophylactic king to b1 this is not
no time to be prophylactic and vasil
goes for knight to f4
so what do you what do you do here uh we
have knight to a5 now
saying that okay you're attacking uh
you're attacking my d5 pawn three times
and also just preparing to eliminate one
of the defenders so i could lose
material here so geary is ready to
eliminate this bishop with
check so he eliminates one of the
attackers to the d5 pawn
so here rook h the e1 here again one
might expect just to rook the g1
uh because we do have the open a semi
open g file we want a double rooks on
the g
file but vasil decides to play it like
they did in the old days when you play
the king's gambit the rooks belong on d1
and e1
and good things will happen so here
anish grabs the bishop we have
knight captures on b3 with check a
captures and
now h6 uh giving uh giving uh vasil
uh deadly there uh he might be
interested in capturing here but he's
not he plays bishop back to h4
and now queen to a5 and now you will see
how black's position
is completely hopeless after vasil plays
king to b1 so now the prophylactic king
the b1 has to be played now it's not
even prophylactic
you know it's just a necessity but after
king to b1
there's no good move for black whatever
you play is just bad to give you an
example
uh okay there's maybe g5 here attacking
two
two of white's pieces but then we can
just eliminate this
bishop here and capture we don't care
about this this is hanging so
black's entire king side just falls
apart and after king to b1 we you you
could also play something like rook
eight to c8
but now you fall into a trap that uh
many a player has fallen for uh when
this diagonal is opened
for example there are plenty of games in
the sicilian you can find
uh where this has happened uh because
now there you can just play knight
captures on d5
and now you're threatening to capture
black's queen so you've just
one material you're threatening knight
after bishop on e7
and here there really is no uh there
there is no good move
here for white whatever you play is just
bad if you trade queens then you just
lose a piece here with
check only after the king moves we're
gonna eliminate the queen and now we're
up a piece
so very very easily winning and other
than that you you don't have a good move
you don't have a move here you could go
back
queen to d8 but then we just play knight
captures queen captures and now knights
to h5
attacking that pinned knight uh and now
uh
we're just going to capture and you know
everything just gets completely
demolished here so instead after king to
b1 anish
plays knights the e for it's his last
attempt uh to try and break through
the white queen is now under attack and
he's also attacking the bishop here on
h4
that is undefended but now we have f
captures on e4 grabbing that knight
bishop captures here and
now only now rook to g1 and rook the g1
is the only winning move here
as you have to be really really quick
the problem is if black tries something
like
captures a pawn then we can just
eliminate this guy and then we've opened
up this diagonal so just captures
captures queen captures on h6 and that's
it there's no defending this the bishop
is under attack
uh after the bishop defends we can play
knight captures an e4
add another attacker here and if the
queen comes to help out with the defense
we can just capture and after let's say
queen captures just bring the rook into
the game for example
queen f7 rook g1 and there are many ways
black can defend this but in all of them
he will lose terribly so instead after
rook to g1 we have bishop to g5
but it doesn't matter here now you could
play something like queen to g2 and then
threaten h4 to eliminate it
to remove the bishop from the defense of
the g7 pawn
but vassal goes for it right away so
here we have h4
bishop captures queen captures and now
king the h8
this is still a threat so king to h8 now
the g
pawn will be able to capture but now
only now e captures on d5 and this is
just
the absolute simplest way to win uh
because it's it's so beautiful the the
bishop of course cannot capture because
then you play queen here
uh to e5 and now you're threatening not
only checkmate but also
to win the piece so uh white would
seriously lose material here
so instead after this e captures on d5
we have bishop to d7
but now comes a move that you have to
find there are many moves many moves are
winning
but one is just completely winning so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the absolute uh
most precise move to win this game for
vasil
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it uh congratulations on always going
for uh always looking for a sacrifice
first and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show
it's queen captures on h6 no it's not
i'm only tricking you it's it's a rook
captures on g7
you had it right uh so here you don't
really have a good response and you have
to capture the rook
otherwise let's say you try something
like queen here to defend the pawn we
can just block this now the queen no
longer defends now you have to capture
and now we go into the same line that
actually happened in the game
so instead uh king captures was played
but now comes
rook to g1 and now the queen and the
rook are completely cutting off the king
from
going anywhere you have to go to the h
file and you have to go to h7 to guard
the h6 spawn so king to h7 was played
and now comes knight to e4 again showing
how
how simple life is for for chalky uh
just going for that f6 square even
though if he wanted to calculate he
could
find the forcing queen to e4 check it's
also very nice so i'm going to show it
king to h8 queen to e5
check now you have to block this
otherwise it's just checkmate so you
have to block this but now you go back
queen e3 again threaten this and now you
try to force the king to h7 to get
this queen to e7 check move it so you
have to defend this but now comes this
with
check and only now after the king moves
now comes this uh
checkmate so it's a very it's a very
beautiful pattern and
you know it's important to know it so
you can you know use this to
check the check the black king not like
that uh
and then at some point the f pawn will
have to move and then you're gonna
remaneuver the queen and you know
deliver checkmate so it might be
useful for you at some point but uh he
goes for the more simpler line
knights to e4 now just going for knight
to f6 check queen to h6 checkmate
f6 there there's no defense you have to
play something knight captures with
czech
rook captures and queen captures now
threatening checkmate here
and after bishop the g4 was played here
okay this bishop to g4 is the one
last super sneaky attempt to buy a niche
to the trick
um into falling for it if the bishop is
captured then you have a draw
by perpetual checking just queenie one
check king here queen goes here king
king to b1 and then you know to infinity
or or three times as the
modern rules um are like that now so
after bishop to g4
uh vassell just played queen to e7 with
check again the absolute simplest way to
win and it was in this position
unmoved 28 that uh anishigiri resigned
the game
and uh this brilliant brilliant victory
was achieved by vasily manchuk
in round seven uh of this uh well very
very nice tournament
yeah very interesting here of course you
resign because the e1 square is now
covered so you will not be able to use
the c1 square for perpetual checking and
after the king moves we're just gonna
capture on g4
and that's it again we're threatening
checkmate there is no defense once you
block this
now we just go in in for the kill you
can deliver check here
check here and now whatever happens is
just going to be checkmate
rook captures or even queen captures
yeah now after queen to e7
uh gear resigned and really really an
awesome game so like i said if you have
any other suggestions of the king's
gambit being played
past 2013 i do suggest as uh
well it's uh it's a beautiful opening
and
always uh you know very impressive games
arise from
uh from using it so thank you again for
such a wonderful suggestion
uh i would like to thank andre tigla
vlad camilla happy birthday hi paul
gregory williams and derek king for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank god i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day